los manifestantes Se tomaron en más a
las calles en la novena jornada de
manifestaciones el jueves y fueron
recibidos con bolillos y gases
lacrimógenos de la policía en la ciudad
suroccidental de burdeos la puerta de la
alcaldía del siglo 18 ardió en llamas
también se produjeron enfrentamientos en
not donde los manifestantes irrumpieron
y saquearon un tribunal administrativo y
en la ciudad de Lil en el norte de
Francia ha sido la jornada más violenta
desde que comenzaron los paros en todo
el país A mediados de enero
cuando 441 policías son atacados con
cócteles Molotov y piedras cuando son
agredidos físicamente hasta el punto de
que algunos siguen hospitalizados la
extrema izquierda quiere atacar a la
República tenemos que enviarle un
mensaje colectivo de condena y la
instrucción que se da ahora a los
policías es que utilicen cierta cantidad
de fuerzas
los sindicatos y partidos de la
oposición culpan al no por no haber
prestado atención a la creciente
indignación ciudadana
el presidente debe Tomar nota de lo que
está ocurriendo en el país
desgraciadamente está jugando con la
violencia está jugando con el caos en el
país en cuestión de días hemos pasado de
las protestas pacíficas a las porras de
la policía
a primera hora del día más de un millón
de manifestantes en su mayoría pacíficos
marcharon por toda Francia según el
Ministerio del interior los sindicatos
cifraron la participación en 3,5
millones de personas igualó el récord
del 7 de marzo el movimiento recibió un
nuevo impulso después de que un
desafiante Emanuel macún se negará a dar
marcha atrás en su reforma de las
pensiones en una entrevista televisada
no quería ni verlo porque me da mucho
asco luego escuché las conclusiones nos
desprecia estoy tan enfadada con él
están encer rados no solo por la reforma
que chilan de injusta sino también por
el uso por parte del presidente de
poderes especiales que forzaron la
aprobación del proyecto sin el voto de
la asamblea nacional los sindicatos han
convocado nuevas huelgas y protestas
para el martes